so I've been participating in the GE
Howcast YouTube physical challenge
I took suggestions from you guys on
things that I should do to get healthy
taylor Runkles suggestion was to do
parkour
I have no former training in parkour so
I took to the Internet and found someone
who could train me in parkour my name is
cliff cravat I'm one of the founders of
PK Khali parkour California parkour is a
discipline discipline of overcoming the
obstacles one's path using just the
human body we're looking to be able to
adapt what whatever our environment be
able to maneuver whatever situations
would be quick fluid movements or slow
stuff and controlled train our bodies
and all our natural abilities so we can
adapt to whatever our path should
encounter we are going to warm up first
so let's do that
first thing we're gonna do first you
want to do we're gonna just do a basic
jumping exercise key here as quiet as
possible now trying to bend girl
g/b
we out there is the mental block and
that that pier that gets you going into
something that you may feel a little
more safe and that's okay that's great
it's one of our obstacles and we go
through progression to overcome in the
few professional almost
no not today not today but another day
yeah how do you think I'm doing so far I
think you're it's good effort just
kidding oh god this is gonna be so
embarrassing you guys are not making fun
of me you are you think of the comments
all right somehow making my lesson here
uh parkour is a lot harder than you
think it is you know it looks really
easy but that's because these people are
in really good shape really good shape
that's Nev I go
I'm just going to say that I'm really
glad we're doing this in a gym and not
outside because concrete is painful so
that's good we're almost done here so
how do you think how do you think it's
going we've progressed a lot just I mean
wow you just leaped over this obstacle
every in real life this is gonna bench
and you're just gonna be oh just like
that just like that
thank you for watching
i justi this has been parkour pika Cali
we're done so what do you think you did
uh you did great
I know it doesn't feel like it but you
do that saying I was very I was very
surprised at how well you you handle
this we threw a lot at you right at once
should I do to like get better all those
exercises we did in the beginning keep
doing them do them outside Dumont stairs
there blasts have fun with him
you know backwards up the stairs do your
basics your your sit ups your push up
your pull-ups just keep on it sounds
awesome thank you so much it's my
pleasure
high five high five whoa all right I'm
inversely bad so what'd you guys think
of my parkour skills yeah not so good
you